- Hi, everyone.
Thank you for joining today on our webinar
on 7 Tips for Motivating
Elementary School Kids
During Distance Learning.
Now, the tips we'll be sharing today
are tailored to this moment,
but they're really applicable
more broadly as needed.
I'm Dan Tu,
and I'll be kicking us off today
as well as moderating the Q&A segment.
But before we get started,
we want to say a special thank
you to several organizations
who have really helped us
with philanthropic support,
enabling us to bring you
programming like today's session.
So we want to say a special
thanks to Bank of America,
Google.org, AT&T,
Fastly, and Novartis.
So I'd like to introduce
you all to Kristen DiCerbo,
who will be walking
through the seven tips,
and sharing her expert advice with you all
while we answer your live questions.
Kristen's our Chief Learning
Officer here at Khan Academy,
and an expert in learning science.
So if you have any
questions on today's topic,
feel free to enter them into the chat.
We have a team collecting
them for the Q&A portion,
and all of this is going
to be recorded and posted.
Since you've registered,
this will automatically be emailed to you.
So don't worry if you miss
anything or need to go back.
So with that, Kristin, take it away.
- Great, thanks.
And thanks all of you for joining today.
I'm going to spend about 15 minutes or so
going through some of the
ideas and the research
behind the tips,
and then we'll open it up for questions,
which I'm sure you all
have lots of in this time.
So to start off with,
as Dan said, I'm the
Chief Learning Officer,
and one of my roles is to bring research
about learning motivation
to our understanding
of how to help students learn.
So all of that that you'll
see here is based on
what we understand about
motivation from research
about how to keep kids motivated.
And one of the first things to understand
is that we can really boil
down a lot of the research
on motivation to a pretty simple formula.
We like to do things when first,
we think we're gonna
be successful at them,
and second, when we
think there's some value
to doing that activity,
which probably makes sense for you
just as much as it does for your kids.
Who wants to do something when you think,
"Oh, I'm probably gonna fail at this"?
You're not likely to do it.
And second, you think
you want to do things
that are important to you.
And so, as we think about
how to motivate our kids,
we can think about how
can I help them feel
like they're likely to be successful
and how can I help them
see some of the value
in this activity?
And so this kind of simple
formula drives a lot of the tips
that I'm gonna be talking about.
And one of the biggest
ways to help kids feel
like they can be successful
at doing something
is to help them experience some success.
And one really good way to
do that is to set goals,
because goals, by definition,
help us see that we're making progress.
And so, as you think about
this with elementary-aged kids,
you want to set really short-term goals.
So if you're talking
kindergartners or first graders,
it could be something as simple as,
"Hey, this afternoon,
we're going to read this book together,"
or "We're going to write three sentences."
What are those things
that you want to work on
just very short-term?
And then at the end you can say,
"Yes, look, we said we were going to try
to write three sentences.
We wrote four sentences."
There's an experience of success.
As kids get a little older,
you can stretch it out.
You can think about in the morning
setting goals for the day.
You can think about
maybe setting a longer,
maybe a week goal that then you
break down into daily goals.
And the other piece that
when you're setting goals
is to help kids think about
how they're gonna know
if they're on track.
So then one of the important pieces here
in both goal setting and monitoring
and making sure they're on track is
to bring the kids into it.
So instead of you saying,
"Our goal is this,"
have the conversation and say,
"So we want to set a goal
about writing sentences.
How many sentences do you
think you can write today?"
So think about helping
them set realistic goals,
and that's then gonna help them be able
to also not just see success,
but also they're going to
value the activity more
because they owned some
of the goal setting
that went along with it.
And so you get actually the
double plus there of thinking
about both success and
value of the activity.
So very strong.
And that's why I encourage
a lot of goal setting
and thinking about how to do that.
But then when you meet them,
definitely celebrate that success.
So this can be everything from
high fives to thinking about,
you know, small, different
things that kids like to do
that they might find successful.
We do everything online from, you know,
a little online confetti to
all kinds of things that just,
you know, recognize that
there's an achievement there.
Also, this can be a good time to reflect.
"Hey, what was it that
helped you be successful
in meeting that goal?"
And "Hey, was there a time
when you were trying to do this
and it was hard and how
did you get over that?
How did you get through the
place where you were stuck?"
And that kind of reflection
helps them then think about,
hey, next time they get
stuck, what might be the,
what might be some strategies
that they could do and work on.
So definitely tip two is
celebrate those successes.
Then thinking about those roadblocks,
think about how you can help
your children have strategies
for when they're going
to get into that place
where they don't know what to do.
And that's going to happen
when you're learning,
because learning is hard.
And when you're actually
engaged in learning,
your learning edge, right when
you're learning new things,
we know that often you
need a little bit of help
to get over that.
But what you want to do is
for your kids to have a plan
for what to do so they don't
get frustrated in that moment.
And before they get frustrated,
you want to make the plan.
So this can be everything
from asking you for help.
If you're also, say, working
from home at the same time
your kids are in school, you
might want to think about,
okay, how do you signal to your kids
when it's okay to come
to you and ask for help
and when they should wait,
and what does that look like?
Are there ways they can
ask their friends for help?
How do they reach out to their teacher
in this kind of place?
So come up with a list of things
that you might be able to work through
to help your kids think about,
"Hey, if I'm stuck,
what are things I can do to get unstuck?"
So you get before they get
to the place of frustration,
they have strategies to use.
After that, think about emphasizing
that effort leads to success.
And there's been a lot of writing recently
about growth mindset and this
idea that if you work hard,
your brain is like a muscle.
And the more you work at it,
the more it's ready to learn new things.
And there's actually
physiology in your brain.
The cells in your brain
are called neurons.
And when we learn new things,
it makes new connections to new neurons.
And that in itself then helps you remember
the things that you've learned.
It makes you a stronger, better learner.
All of that is better in a better message.
And research shows,
kids who understand and get
some of that understanding
of how their brain works
actually do persist more
than students who just say,
"Hey, keep trying, hey, keep going."
And so actually at Khan Academy,
we have a growth mindset course
where we have a couple of videos
that explain some of
this in language for kids
to understand that can
be good to just, again,
start thinking of those
messages that your brain
is like other muscles and
it needs to keep practicing
and keep learning new things.
That'll actually make you
better and a better learner.
So that's the fourth tip,
thinking about effort leading to success.
The fifth one is to
engage their curiosity.
So lots of kids are curious
about different things
that happen in the world.
It could be when they're
riding their bikes
and they're thinking, "How does, you know,
pushing on this pedal actually
make the wheels turn?"
any of those kinds of questions.
It's okay if you don't know the answer.
Think about how you can find out answers
to those things together.
And when we think about kids
that are curious about the world,
those are the kids that keep learning
and keep trying to find new things.
And so you want to encourage
those kinds of questions.
You can also model asking
So as you're doing
things around the house,
or as you're doing things outside,
asking questions about how the world works
and thinking about, "Hey,
did you ever wonder,"
and "How can you find
the answers to those?"
All of those help build up
that internal motivation
to find answers and understand the world.
The sixth tip I have is
to establish relevance.
So it relates to what I was just saying
about linking things to the world.
But the other way to do this is
think about what your kids are learning
and help them link that to things
that are of interest to them.
You know your kid's
interests better, really,
than even their teachers do.
So if you can think about
how do I help them see
how this relates to a hobby
that they're interested in?
How does this relate to
something they want to be
when they grow up?
How does this relate to something
we talked about yesterday?
All of those things help
students establish the value
of what they're learning.
So if we go back to that equation,
that second piece of
why should I learn this,
what is this going to help me do,
how does this relate to
things I'm interested in,
if you can help make those connections,
kids will value the activity more
and be more likely to
want to engage in it.
And finally, the seventh tip.
I hear lots of concerns and we
get lots of questions about,
"Should I use rewards?
I don't want to be bribing
my student to work."
And I would say rewards are
absolutely a part of what we do
and how we reward ourselves.
Even those of us who, you know,
are successful and are
good students have tricks
to keep ourselves motivated.
I often say and do, when
I'm writing, I will say,
"If I write one page here,
I'll reward myself with
a piece of chocolate."
You know, all of that is fine,
but you want to think about
how to do this wisely.
So the danger of rewards is sometimes
that if a kid is already
interested in doing something,
like it's already bringing
them happiness and joy,
and you start rewarding it
with external things like candy
and those kinds of things,
they start to lose, actually,
some of their internal
motivation and start thinking,
"Oh, I'm just doing this for the reward."
So that's what we want to avoid.
But rewards can be really good for things
that students just
don't want to do at all,
but need a little bit of
kickstart to get going,
and then maybe experience
some of the success,
experience meeting a goal in it,
to get from thinking about
how we can use those extrinsic rewards
to getting to more of those intrinsic,
"Oh, actually I am good at this.
I can learn math."
Those extrinsic rewards
are really good at that.
And they don't have to be things.
They can be picking what's for dinner.
They can be picking
which TV show you watch,
spending, you know, another
15 minutes of screen time,
taking a walk with you,
having some of your time individually,
all of those things are good rewards.
And it's also good to ask your kids
what's rewarding to them,
what would they like to
be rewards for things
that meeting goals and making progress.
And that way, again,
you're making sure you've got something
that's meaningful to them
and helping them learn
how to think about rewarding themselves.
And when they need to
get a little extra kick
to get something done,
to be able to think about
how to use rewards wisely for themselves.
So that said, that
gives us our seven tips,
thinking about setting goals
and monitoring progress,
celebrating success, help your
kids manage those roadblocks,
emphasize that effort leads to success,
encourage curiosity, establish relevance,
and use rewards wisely.
So with that,
I'm going to open it up,
because I'm sure there are
specific questions that you have
about your situations
and how to deal with some of the things,
the specifics that you're facing.
So would be glad to
hear some of those, Dan?
- Yeah, well, so before we get to that,
just a couple of things
that we'd all ask you to do.
First, there's, in the handout
section of the webinar,
you can download a printable
version of these seven tips.
That's available in the download section.
And again, if you registered
and you're actually
watching this live now,
once this video, this webinar's over,
you'll get an email with the
recording of this webinar,
as well as a link to the downloadable.
So again, if you want to go back
and both watch any of
the tips in particular
or read about them, that'll
be available to you.
And then secondly,
go ahead and start putting in
any of the questions you have.
Even specific examples would be great.
And we'll try to get through
as many of them as possible.
So with that, Kristen,
the first question we
have is from Rebecca.
And I think you mentioned
this in terms of tip,
I believe it's tip number six.
How can you help kids feel
like what they're learning
in school and what they
do is really relevant
to their lives?
- So the biggest thing here is
to think about understanding
what is interesting to your kids.
So what are things that
they're interested in
is the first piece and then
relating things to them.
So the most common place
we hear this is in math.
And so there's some things
that are pretty easy relatable to math.
So one thing is cooking.
Cooking, it turns out,
involves a lot of math,
specifically, a lot of fractions.
There can be, you know, if
you're doing a double batch,
how do you think about
doubling a fraction?
What does that look like?
Thinking about how that actually applies,
the things that they're doing
apply to their daily life.
So cooking is always a good example
for a lot of math issues.
There are also things
that you can think about.
What do they want to be when they grow up?
Maybe they don't know. That's okay, too.
You can think about what kinds of careers
are the skills they're learning good for.
So, hey, these are the kinds of things,
I know we don't know what you
want to be when you grow up.
You haven't decided what you
It's a good idea to kind of
experience a bunch of different,
find out about a bunch of
different possibilities.
So, "Hey, this thing
that we're learning now,
it turns out that this is something
that accountants use a lot,"
or "This is something that
someone who's doing a lot of,
who's an oceanographer learns
a lot about these topics
that you're learning
about in science today,
thinking about those,
the kinds of careers,
that link to the different
things that they're learning
is another way to bring
some of this to life.
And I would also not hesitate to reach out
to your kids' teachers for
help in thinking about,
"Hey, can you give us a
preview of what's coming?"
And what do they think
are good ways to help them
relate that to things
they see in their lives?
But there's lots of things
in our everyday lives.
I gave the bicycle example.
It turns out that's all about
simple machines and pulleys
and chains and all of that.
So all of those kinds of
examples of how the world works,
we can find things that kids are learning
that relate to them.
But it takes some work, I will admit.
- No, that's great, Kristen.
I would say like one thing, as well, is
use all of your senses as a parent.
Like there are things that
the child might not tell you,
like they want to do this,
they want to do that.
But you know, your child best.
And if you know that they love
doing this activity, yeah,
and just be observant of
that and try to relate that
back to the, again, back to the subject.
Cool.
So Kristen, we have a
question from Jay Tinder.
Apologies if I mispronounce the name.
Any tips for helping motivate
elementary kids transitioning
to middle school in a
distance learning environment?
So really that transition
period, meeting new friends,
those types of things.
So any advice you have there.
- So there's a number of
things that go on when kids
transition to middle school.
So you mentioned, Dan,
meeting new friends.
There's also kids that are
taking on and required to take on
a little bit more ownership,
a little bit more self responsibility.
And it's in,
when we talk about distance learning,
one of the things we know
about distance learning is
that kids who are best at it
are kids who are what we
call self-regulated learners.
So those are kids
that are actually
capable of setting goals,
capable of monitoring their own progress,
kids that can create, organize
schedules for themselves.
Those are all skills that
you can help your child with.
So think about helping them set up,
what is their schedule for the day.
Because the other piece that
often happens in middle school
is you start switching teachers.
Where in elementary
school, you just had one,
now you have multiple teachers.
So help your child think about
how do they set out a schedule
of what the day looks like
so they make sure to know
what the expectations are.
Help them think about and let
them be part of the process.
Let them, you know,
you can maybe give them a
skeleton and let them fill it out.
And next time they create what the,
next week they create what
the schedule looks like.
So kind of gradually
pulling back from the things
that you're doing and letting
them have some ownership
and some agency.
And it turns out that a lot of kids
are really motivated by that.
If they know that you've
kind of got them there
as a safety net and that you're
there to kind of catch them
if things get too rough.
So I would say, give them
a little bit more agency.
They're going to then find more ownership
in valuing the activities
because they're driving
them and choosing them.
And help them see that
and take on a little bit
more of that ownership.
Dan, you mentioned, you know,
the pieces about making new friends,
and often middle schools
are bringing together
a bunch of elementary schools.
And now that we're at distance,
it's so difficult to create
some of those peer connections.
And peers start to become
more and more important
for kids at this age level.
So the more you can help facilitate things
in this distance environment,
we're really limited, but
facilitating, you know,
at least calls or Hangouts,
ways for kids to informally
connect with each other
and be able to do some
activities together online
that maybe they wouldn't be
able to do in person these days,
but to help keep some of
those peer relationships going
and to try to build them
in these new places.
But understand the other piece you may do
is to empathize with your kids and say,
"I know this is tough right now,
and this is going to be difficult
as we're moving forward.
I know you miss your friends,"
and just give them a
chance to share with you
and to express some of
what they're feeling, too,
as they're kind of making
some of these transitions.
- Yeah, I think that's
a great point, Kristen,
great points.
I think when you transition
to middle school,
not only do you have more teachers,
but you have to control
your schedules more,
you know, which classrooms
are you going to when.
So you're learning a lot of like agency
and being responsible and
getting to class on time.
And like you said,
you're meeting like tons of
new kids from different schools
that you're going to at the same time.
So I do think there's a lot
of challenges for those kids.
- Absolutely.
And if you can pinpoint which
things your kid is good at
and highlight those
and find out where some
of the weaknesses are
and help support those,
that's a good way for
you to help support them
and tailor it to what their needs are.
- So we have a question from Dora.
I think we get,
we hear this question a lot,
is how do you manage roadblocks?
So when your child has self-doubt
or developing low self esteem,
especially in this distance
learning environment,
how do you manage those
and help the child overcome those moments?
- Yeah, so kids who are, you know,
not feeling like they're learners
or they're feeling like,
"Math is not for me.
I'm not, you know, not
good at these things.
I don't know how to do this,"
all of those are things
where kids can really benefit
from things like the growth mindset piece
that I was talking about.
This idea that none of us
is fixed in our ability
to do things.
We can always get better and
getting better takes work.
But it's actually pretty
rewarding when you start to see,
"Hey, I used to be able to do
this and now I can do this.
Here's a new thing that I can do now
that I couldn't do before."
So one, give them the
messages about thinking about
we can always improve.
Our brains improve. Our brains
change as we try new things.
That's really important.
But also thinking about helping them
experience some success.
So those small goals and thinking about
how to get them to see
a little bit of progress
that they're making.
And even a little bit of progress is good.
"Yesterday you couldn't do
the two-digit by minus two-digit problems.
And today you did three
of them. That's great."
Like legitimately, that's progress.
That's very good.
So helping them see, again,
that they can have a little bit of success
and that really does build on itself
and help kids start to see
themselves as learners.
And that's really the key that
then will kick things off.
- Great. So Kristen, we
have a lot of questions.
And it goes back to the very first tip,
which is setting goals.
We have a couple of questions
around goals, first from Sue.
She loves the idea of setting goals,
but they're already
being set by the school.
So how do you match what your,
the goals that your schools are setting?
Another question from Flavio is like,
how do we know we're setting
goals at the appropriate level?
And you know, whether
it's too challenging,
not challenging enough.
And then the third is from Ed,
who's asking for very specific examples
for their grade school kid.
They're having challenges
with getting their child
to help set their own goals.
- Got it. So, yeah, lots
of, lots of good stuff.
So the first thing I
would say that underlies
all of those is,
think about talking to
your child's teacher,
even in this distance world,
keeping those lines of communication open.
So if a teacher starts hearing, like,
"All of the things that you're
asking us to do every day
is too much.
Like, the kids can't handle that much."
And they start hearing that from parents,
they're gonna adjust what they're doing.
Or they're gonna, you know,
start to find ways to help the students
and provide more support,
one or the other.
But if the teacher doesn't know
that the kids are struggling
to do this,
and it can be difficult to know that
when they are in a distance
learning situation,
then they don't know that
the kids need extra help
or that they need to think about
how much they're putting on kids.
Because a lot of teachers
may have tons of experience
doing all of this in
the regular classroom,
but it's not clear how
much kids can take on
in these distance learning situations.
So that's my first piece of
advice is to think about how to,
you know, talk to your teacher
about if the goals are too much,
or if they're thinking about, you know,
if they're not meeting them
or where they need to go.
And Dan, I have lost,
there were a bunch of questions there,
and I lost, (giggles)
in my short term memory,
a couple of the other points.
Could you remind me of what those were?
- So the other one is, how do we know when
it's like the right level
of goal for the child,
in addition to your teacher one.
And then I think the third one was,
how do you get your kids to
kind of play into goal setting
if your kid's reluctant to kind of engage
with the goal setting exercise, right?
So if they're not happy to
share with you what they think,
like, how do you pull that out of them?
- Great. Yep.
So the level of goals
piece is another one to,
it's really good to talk
to your student's teacher,
talk to your kid's
teacher about, you know,
what kinds of levels that they're at,
because it is going to
be individual for kids.
But then it should be as
something that you're looking for,
you want kids to, if you're
kind of observing them do work,
you want to think about there's
something where they have to
put in effort.
And there's something that we talked about
that's called productive struggle.
And it means that kids are,
they're having to put in
some cognitive efforts,
like think hard about this
and reason through it.
And it's not just coming easy to them.
If it's coming really easy,
it's probably too low a goal.
If they're getting really frustrated,
it's probably too high a goal.
So something kind of in between there
is what you're looking to hit,
where there is a little
bit of struggle going on.
Maybe they're a little bit confused.
Maybe they're not sure how to do this.
Maybe they need a little bit
of help. That is all okay.
Those are all signs
that they're right about
at the right place.
They don't need to be
doing it independently.
If they could just breeze
through it independently,
probably too easy.
So that's kind of what you're
looking for in terms of
where the step, what that is.
But a good guide is looking at the things
that your teachers,
that your child's teacher's assigning
and thinking about,
you know, how that can,
how you can help break that down.
The other piece to that
first question was, you know,
it seems to be too much,
that's being assigned.
Again, think about breaking
down into small pieces.
So you can a little bit of
progress even after an hour.
"What are we going to
try to do in this hour?
I know it's a whole bunch of stuff.
Let's just focus on this
thing we can get done now,
and then we can worry about
the rest of it later."
So all of that is good goal setting.
And then if you've got kids that are just,
that are not engaging
and are not that good at setting goals,
we can think about, again,
that idea of rewards and
thinking about engaging them,
and maybe if you're
initially setting a goal
and then having them in the conversation
about what they think maybe
would be a good reward
for getting into that, reaching that goal.
So all of that can kind of help
bring them into the process
and what that is.
So maybe they're not
interested in setting the goal
the first time.
'Cause then you can think about
what's the reward for that.
Or you can think about
rewards for helping set goals.
We're getting very kind of meta there.
But then again, rewards can
be good for helping kids
start doing something that
they're not interested in doing.
So think about, you know,
"Hey, let's set this goal and
then we can go and, you know,
chase around in the backyard
with the dog for 30 minutes,
and then we can get back
to work on a meeting."
Those kinds of things, you
know, are all good ways
to start to kind of
encourage that behavior.
- That's great.
And we have a question,
we have a couple questions around feedback
and that portion of the tips.
So Rebecca asks,
what type of feedback
is most helpful for kids
and does it depend on the stage
of where they're learning?
So things like the frequency
of the feedback, the timing,
when to acknowledge, you know,
basically effort versus
results, things like that?
- Yup, yup. All good, excellent questions.
This is actually some place
where there's a pretty good
amount of research out there.
So when you were just
learning a new thing,
you want to give immediate feedback
that is both about whether
it's correct or not,
but also why it's correct or not.
So that's what we call elaborated feedback
because it's not just the
correctness, but it's the why.
And so you want that to
be specific to the task
that they're doing.
You don't want to give
that general feedback like,
"Oh, you're so smart."
You want to keep it as "You
got that question right.
Good job."
"That answer is right because XYZ."
or "You didn't get that
one right that time.
That answer's not correct
because of XYZ. Let's try again."
Again, don't make it about
characteristics of the child.
You want to think about
trying to give feedback.
So feedback on correctness
and about why it's correct or not is good.
And you can also then combine that
with feedback about effort.
So something like, "Wow,"
if you're seeing that productive struggle
that I was talking about,
like they've worked pretty hard
to get to this answer, like,
"Wow, I saw you really
thinking hard about that.
That's great.
Let's take a look at whether
we got it right or wrong,
or whether we want to try again."
And then you can move into
the correctness feedback.
As kids are more advanced
and they're getting into
more advanced topics
and are kind of more
comfortable with things,
it's actually good to
have them have a chance
to reflect on whether they think
something's correct or not.
So we do things like saying,
"How confident are you in that answer?
How sure are you,
how sure are you that that's right?"
And get them to actually start
building some of those skills
where they're kind of mentally
checking their own work,
which is a good skill
to have and think about,
and then give them the feedback.
It can be a little bit more delayed.
It doesn't need to be quite as immediate
as kids are getting a
little bit more advanced.
- So perhaps we have time
for one more question.
Unfortunately, we have
a lot more questions
than we have time for.
So we'll try to, you know,
potentially address it in the
future in a future webinar.
But Melissa asks, and it's a
little bit related to feedback,
which is, when should you
step back and allow a break,
if your child's just really
reluctant or really frustrated.
When you recognize that and
then when do you actually engage
or when do you disengage?
- Yeah. Excellent question.
So first I would say,
we want to prioritize our
kids' emotional wellbeing
in all of this.
We don't want to let kids get to the point
where they're, you know,
breaking down in tears about things,
because that's going to
take a lot to then walk back
and get down and get
settled and where that is.
So the more you can be proactive
in scheduling in breaks
and taking a step away
even before they're showing
signs of being upset,
that's actually good too.
So don't be hesitant to take breaks.
Breaks are good for everybody.
But if you've kind of
gotten through there,
but your child is still
like really frustrated,
absolutely take a break.
Go back to those strategies.
"Okay, let's take a
break, do something else."
And then I tend to go back,
have a little bit of discussion
about what's really frustrating them.
Where is that road block?
Is it they don't know what to do next?
They can't get this right?
They can't understand it?
You know, then you can start
to problem solve about,
okay, if you understand what
it is that's so frustrating.
Is it that it's just too much
that they're thinking about?
Is it that, you know,
they're worried about all
of the other things going on
in the world, or they,
where are those things?
So the more you can have a
conversation, take a break,
get away from it,
then have a conversation
about how are they feeling,
what are the things that
they're worried about?
What are the things that are
frustrating them and see if you
can problem solve some of those together.
But absolutely look for
those body language signs
that kids are getting
really upset and frustrated
and try to cut things off if you can,
before it gets too far down that road.
- Well, I think that's
great advice for adults
as much as kids.
I think that's some good
advice for us all to follow.
So huge apologies. We have
so many more questions.
Like I said, perhaps we can
tackle more in a future webinar.
But with that,
I'd like to thank Kristen for
her sharing her expert advice
with our audience.
And we want to thank you, our audience,
for taking time out of your
busy schedule to be with us.
We know you're incredibly
busy during this time.
And so we really appreciate
you investing your time
to this session.
If you missed anything or want
to go back and review again,
this is being recorded.
And not only are we going to post it,
but for those of you who have registered,
this will automatically be emailed to you.
And in addition to that,
as well as the downloadable
with the seven tips
that Kristen mentioned before.
So don't miss, you know,
don't worry if you missed anything.
And we also have quite a few
resources at khanacademy.org
if you need more information.
And before we sign off,
we want to ask that you
do two things for us.
First, please answer the
poll that happens at the end,
that pops up at the end of this webinar.
We want to ask, you know,
how can we make future
iterations of this session
even better for you?
And then secondly, what
kind of other sessions
would you like to see us
develop in the future?
And we're here to help you.
So please let us know
how we can best do that.
And so from all of us at
Khan Academy, thank you.
And goodbye.